Hi, I'm Greg DeMichillie.
I'm a Director of Product
Management here at Google.
And I work on the
Google Cloud Platform.
Today, we have
some exciting news
about Compute Engine we
want to share with you.
Compute Engine is Google's
virtual machine technology.
It allows you to run
any type of application
you want on top of Google's
infrastructure and data
centers.
Now, the Cloud Platform
also includes App Engine,
which is our platform
as a service offering
that lets you easily build and
scale web apps or mobile back
ends.
We also have a variety
of storage products,
from SQL to NoSQL databases.
And all of these are
managed and operated
by Google using our
15 years of expertise
in building hardware and
software infrastructure.
And if you take it
all together, they
give you the flexibility
you need to build and deploy
virtually any type
of application.
But today, we're here to
talk about Compute Engine.
This is a big day
for Compute Engine
and for the Cloud
Platform, because we've
reached a new milestone.
I'm excited to announce
that Compute Engine has
reached general availability.
What that means is you now
have virtual machines that
have the performance,
reliability, security,
and scale of Google's
own infrastructure.
In addition to customer
support and a high monthly SLA,
this milestone represents
our internal and external
commitment to the service
and to delivering to you
a great developer experience.
We have over 1,000
engineers working
on continuing to make
the cloud platform better
for Google itself and
for you, our customers.
Now, before we go too far
in looking at new features
that we're announcing,
let me give you
a tour of just what sort of
performance and reliability
you can expect from
Compute Engine.
This is a little
app that will spawn
a number of Compute
Engine virtual machines.
In this case, I'm
going to have it
start 1,000 virtual machines.
When I click Start, it's
using the Compute Engine APIs
to launch those
virtual machines.
And it has a timer running to
keep track of how long it took.
As the virtual
machines are launched,
the boxes turn
from grey to green,
indicating that the VM
has launched successfully.
Now, this will take
a couple minutes
to launch these 1,000
virtual machines.
So we're going to let
that run in the background
while I continue to
talk to you a bit.
Let's talk about some
of the new features
that we're announcing today.
First, Compute
Engine now supports
transparent maintenance windows.
What this means is that as we
do the maintenance and upgrades,
whether it's software or
hardware or networking,
in our data centers,
your application
continues to run unimpacted.
We move your virtual
machine out of the way
while we're performing
the maintenance.
You get the benefits of an
up-to-date, maintained patch
data center without having the
impact on your applications.
This is available today in our
United States data centers.
And we'll be rolling it
out to Europe shortly.
In addition, we have
automatic restarts.
This means in the event of an
unplanned event or a hardware
failure, your application will
restart as quickly as possible.
This was a commonly
requested feature
from many of our
customers, including
some of our
enterprise customers.
Now, turning to
operating systems,
until now we've
supported Debian and
CentOS-based virtual machines.
Well, today we're
opening that up.
Not only can you run FreeBSD,
you can run any out-of-the-box
Linux distro.
And with one click
in the admin console,
you can launch SUSE or Red
Hat virtual machines directly.
SUSE and Red Hat are
in limited preview.
And the other Linux distros
are available today.
We've also added new, more
powerful Compute Engine
instance types.
We know there's
customers out there who
want to run even more demanding
compute-intensive applications.
So starting today, you can
launch virtual machines
with up to 16 cores.
These are available in
our standard, high CPU,
and high memory configurations.
[INAUDIBLE]
This means you can bring
even more demanding loads
onto Compute Engine.
Now of course, app
performance isn't just
about number of
cores and memory.
It also is about
disk performance.
We know from talking to
customers that Persistent Disk
performance is a key factor.
So starting today,
Persistent Disk
is up to eight times faster.
This means you can now bring
your more I/O-intensive
and disk-intensive workloads to
Compute Engine and have a great
experience running
those as well.
Now, before we go
on, let's go over
and see how those virtual
machines that we started up
are doing.
Here we are.
We're back.
And all the boxes
have turned green,
which means all 1,000
VMs are up and running.
And if we look at the time,
it was 2 minutes, 41 seconds.
That's a pretty quick
way to start 1,000 VMs.
So in addition to
new features, we also
continue to support major
enterprise customers.
We have 24 by 7 support,
a monthly SLA of 99.95%.
So you have
guarantees of uptime,
as well as important
certification,
such as ISO 27001
or SOC 1, 2, and 3.
Finally, we're continuing
to pass on the savings
from building and operating ever
more efficient data centers.
We're also reaffirming
our commitment
to offer the best compute
price performance.
We're doing that
by lowering prices
on our most popular
instance type
by 10% across the
board in all regions.
We've also heard from customers
that cost predictability
and I/O performance are key
factors for Persistent Disk.
So not only are we making
it eight times faster,
we're making it
up to 60% cheaper.
We're also eliminating
any charge for I/O.
You simply purchase
the capacity you need,
and you get great I/O for free.
You get way more performance at
a great and predictable price.
Of course, when you're
building an application,
support for partners
and ISVs is critical.
The ecosystem around
Compute Engine
is large and growing quickly.
The software you're
familiar with, whether it's
from RightScale or Scalr,
New Relic, MapR, MongoLabs,
all runs great on
Google Cloud Platform.
Google Cloud Platform gives you
the performance, reliability,
scalability, and
security that we
expect from our
own applications.
You can get started today with
Compute Engine and the Google
Cloud Platform.
Just go to cloud.google.com,
sign up for a new account,
and you can start
creating applications.
One of the most fun things about
working on the Cloud Platform
is seeing the amazing apps that
you, the developers, create.
So I hope you'll go out,
create some great applications,
engage with us on Google+ or any
of the other social networks.
We love hearing about what
you've built with the platform.
Thanks for listening.